There are two other texture mapping methods that can add considerable detail to
a model. The first is displacement mapping. Here a texture, called a height
field, is used to change the height of the surface itself at each vertex. In
other words, each vertex has a u v value. This value is used to retrieve the
height value from the texture. The height value is then used to displace the
vertex. In other words, move it upward or downward along it's normal. However,
simply displacing the vertices does not change the shading normals of the
surrounding surface. You would see the bumpiness and the silhouette of the
object, but otherwise the shading would look fairly similar to the original. To
change the shading normals themselves, another texture is applied to the
surface. This texture is called a normal map, and is considerably different
than other textures we've encountered up to this point. Here's the displacement
map for the model, and here's what the normal map looks like. The grey level of
this height field shows the amount to displace the vertex, with brighter pixels
pushing farther above the original surface. The normal map is, in fact, derived
from this displacement map, and there are tools to create this type of texture.
Each normal in a normal map is found from the differences in the nearby heights
in the displacement map. You can always tell a normal map by its distinctive
light blue. The normal map stores an xyz direction vector at each texel. When
we view this xyz value as an RGB color, we get this type of look. Specifically
the red channel is x, with positive to the right, the green channel is y with
positive up, and blue is the z axis. This xyz space is relative to the surface
of the model and is called tangent space. If the normal is not to be changed at
all, the normal stored is 0, 0, 1, straight at the z axis. A value of 127 in
this texture means 0. A value of 255 means 1. The light blue then comes from an
x and y value of 0, which gives a red and green channel of 127. The z value is
1, giving a blue channel of 255. So an unchanged normal has an RGB of 127, 127,
255, a light blue. The basic idea is that you're using this normal value to
change the existing shading normal. The normal in the texture map takes the
place of the shading normal, and relative to the shading normal's original
direction. Here's the interesting part. Once you have the normal map, you don't
have to apply the displacement map. They're separate processes. The
displacement map moves the vertices. The normal map modifies the shading
normals. Here we have, from left to right, the unmodified head, the head with
just normal mapping, and the head with both. While the model with both mappings
is the most convincing, using just the normal map gives you much of what you
want but with many less triangles. In fact, artists often first create highly
detailed geometric models. A program can then bake the normals into a normal
map. The mesh can then be simplified, saving both processing time and memory
while retaining much of the detail as the original. Having a surface that is
smooth but has differing shading normals is not something we usually see in the
real world. In reality, bumps are what cause the surface to change its
orientation; however, it's fine in computer graphics to have one without the
other. We've already been using the idea that the shading normal can be
different than the geometric surface normal. Here we are extending that idea.
Varying the shading normal per texel instead of per vertex.